[Music]
building the club for everyone takes
everyone to create and embrace a culture
that is inclusive and representative of
our communities here at next nineteen in
San Francisco diversity equality and
inclusion is part of our DNA
recently Forbes magazine recognized
their commitment naming next as one of
the top three conferences for women to
thrive let's check in with Joanna for
more on the inclusion lounge and the
hash tag I am remarkable workshops
happening here at next thanks so much
Stephanie I'm so excited to be here at
our inclusion lounge because diversity
is something that I obviously care a lot
about but more important than just being
diverse is making sure that we have
multiple perspectives at the table so
that we can build really interesting
solutions to fun problems so now we're
talking to tailor who drives diversity
equity and inclusion that next hi thank
you this lounge is great you want to
tell me some fun facts about it
welcome to the inclusion lounge and you
know the purpose of the inclusion lounge
is to make sure that at necks were
always providing content and experiences
to support underrepresented groups and a
life to be able to come together share
learnings collaborate and build
communities so yeah it's a it's a safe
space and it at any time people could
drop by connect with like-minded others
get confidence coaching and also get
head shots and then
interim we also have sessions like I'm
remarkable which is going on right
around our shoulder yeah and this
session is happening a couple times at
Meg's and it takes us through an
exercise of empowerment and learning how
to promote ourselves in all the positive
ways what do you think really makes the
inclusion loud to stand out and why
should people think about coming here
during their day yeah you know it it's
not even about thinking about it it's
just knowing that it's available because
so much about inclusion is you have to
be ready to be in the space yes and when
you're ready to receive and you're ready
to learn from others and become an ally
or become an advocate that's the time to
actually visit and it shouldn't be an
intimidating space it should be a space
where you could feel like you could be
welcomed you can meet like-minded people
and you can actually learn and listen
from one another our attendees are
always sharing with us that whether
they're an introvert or an extrovert
they need a place to unwind and step
away from the commotion up next and all
the wonderful experiences that are
available here and then they're really
able to then go from a collaborative
mindset rather than an overwhelmed by
set thank you again for building this
space
I really admire it thanks for coming to
talk to us about it and all we feel that
you could drop by at the inclusion
lounge because we all know it's really
important that next to build a cloud for
everyone thanks everyone
[Music]
you